you guys i have got
[Music]
a treasure chest this is a very special
treasure chest
this treasure chest came from peter
mckinnon this has been sitting
maybe for a few weeks sitting over there
waiting because i didn't want to open it
unless i was doing this on camera so
let's do i don't even know how to open
this
do i need to like do i need tools i
don't i just need
i need my fingers and my brain so you
guys might notice that we have a little
new set
because i decided to turn my room into
an apple store and then
we didn't put it back to how it was
before so now we can have some more room
for activities or set pieces
and this is going to look so good back
there let's see what it looks like
before i open it i know you guys let me
open it but i just want to see
yeah that's nice put this skull on top
of it
oh that's nice it even has my name on it
like it's custom
this is a custom pirate treasure chest
it's all very wait there's something on
the bottom
too look at that oh wow
this is pirate treasure
[Applause]
[Music]
oh i'm so excited
i really do feel like i went out and i
dug this up
but i didn't i just went and got the
mail whoa
look at this oh man
what a great logo
lens cap lids this is everything
we always need these look at that
there's little stickers
so that we can label all of our lenses
this is so cool what is this
limited edition artisan crafted handmade
in the usa
what do you know what this is
[Music]
oh my god this is so cool it's a tumbler
that started out
as molten glass took 20 minutes to
create uniquely mine
one of one that's impressive oh my god
this is so nice
it's got the little skull logo at the
bottom oh what
this is incredible i'm gonna drink my
yerba mate out of this
something in here smells good
okay i saw this on his instagram it's
the candle but look at this container
it's like a little vintage can
there it is oh this smells incredible
put your snout on that
whoa ah yeah what whoa
it smells so good if that's what pirates
smell
like sign me up i am gonna hit the high
seas
i wish they could smell it what is the
scent
it's incredible i mean i bet peter went
down there and looted the titanic for
this
like he would do that what is this
what is this what is all this stuff
there's so much treasure in here like i
don't even know where to start
rip it and stick it
all those stickers wow these are
neat oh man look how cool these are
i'm gonna put these on my pelican case
wait a minute
i found my next tattoo this is it this
is it i love i love knives
i've been looking into 3d printing
knives i found some incredible
cs go ones that are currently in the
works
what's this
notebooks these are so
nice i love the design i love the matte
black
more notes write it or lose it
these are so cool what is it here
is this a mask
it is a mask look at this detail like
check that out like this is
this is some serious quality we're like
not even done yet
captain's secret sauce
oh my gosh it's hot sauce oh no way
it's the editor's secret recipe okay so
i need to set my game up
i gotta step my game up because i love
anything
i don't have a single piece of merch
this is i'm gonna put this on my eggs
tomorrow morning
what's in here
this knife goes very well with this
packaging
oh
[Music]
it's a pen oh my gosh
this is for the notes that we're gonna
take
i'm going to write a note
you cool you cool dude
here do you want a pen too tyler i share
the pen with you
here let me i'll open it for you just to
see if it's a different one
yeah you gotta go write your notes we
gotta we gotta we gotta get merch
the only type of pen that i usually
carry is a tactical pen
that's basically for not writing this is
really cool
wow we're gonna be writing notes there's
so much stuff
in here we're not even done yet a zipper
pool
oh these are cool these are getting
replaced on all of my lululemon
jackets here tyler look at you for your
zippers
what i have these on my backpack already
really
no way wow and wait there's still
something else
we still have one more thing everything
about i'm gonna
i'm freaking out like what is this
there's a small
little tiny box inside of here
shut up shut up
oh my goodness this is so cute
wait does this open does this oh i
thought this was it
is there something else in here wait i
just thought it was a cool box
what is this i just thought it was a box
oh my god look how cool this is
[Music]
this is real life pirate treasure oh my
god
freaking out man look at this
i think i need to get a matching skull
tattoo on the other side
what do you think i just thought that
this was a cool box
but little did i know that there is a
treasure inside of it
oh my gosh a secret coin pouch
this is the coolest thing i've ever seen
like nothing else is ever going to
compare to this
what a freaking sweet surprise i'm so
happy
thank you so much this is incredible
thank you
you